123 mehrzahl der patienten die bei uns
verstorben sind sind an der infektion
gestorben egal von welcher welt leben
wir sind wir alle permanent angestanden
es ist eine komplett neue situation die
auf 1 zu bekommen ist wirklich sehr
viele patienten aufnehmen müssen die
vorher besucht und man hatte angst ein
wenig natürlich auch respekt davor wie
kommen einmal ein bisschen primär auf
die seite schieben wir den arm einmal
schon mal drunter
natürlich gehen einen einzelnen
schicksale werner wir warten einfach
darauf dass es jetzt besser wird ohne
diese pfleger und diese tollen ärzte
werde nicht so weit gekommen
[Musik]
insgesamt ist man natürlich immer
intensiv medizin mit dem thema sterben
und tod täglich konfrontiert hätte ich
in der ausbildung bewusst dass unsere
eine pandemie treffen wird in diesem
ausmaß nicht trotzdem für die
intensivstation entschieden
[Musik]